if you decide to pick up Robin a
heinlein's novel Starship Troopers
because you've enjoyed Paul verhoven's
movie version you might be disappointed
and vice versa these are the biggest
distinctions between the 1959 book and
its film adaptation
to this day some film critics and
audiences still don't quite get Starship
Troopers sometimes taking it for genuine
pro-military propaganda when in fact
that's tongue-in-cheek satire labord one
of the most misunderstood movies ever by
the Atlantic it seems that many failed
to notice how the film's comically
exaggerated style was poking fun at the
ridiculous nature of fascist
authoritarianism rather than condoning
it however some of the confusion is a
little more understandable when one is
more acquainted with the book which is
wildly different in tone and as a more
sincere pro-military message for those
familiar with the movie it might raise
an eyebrow to learn that Combat Action
only plays a small role in the Starship
Troopers book author Robert a Heinlein
was much more interested in discussion
of moral philosophy critiques of early
20th century liberalism individual
rights and responsibility to the
collective the book is also filled to
the brim with detailed explorations of
the command structure and tactics of the
mobile infantry making it often feel
like a technical manual cool but the
book is indeed overtly political the
bugs are described in though in certain
terms as representing communism and
several key passages and views on the
benefits of authoritarianism over a free
democracy
though some critics didn't see it at the
time Starship Troopers the film was an
attempt by director Paul verhoven to
criticize Hyland's belief in a
government ostensibly run by the
military for those reading the bug for
its right-wing political message the
film's clear satire likely ruffled more
than a few feathers assuming they
noticed it at all
in Paul verhoven's 1997 film The
romantic love quadrangle involving Rico
Carmen dizzy and Xander sits at the
center of the story you could argue that
the movie is as much about Rico's
attempt to find love as it is about
Earth's battle with a race of
interstellar insects but in the original
novel there's no such romance to speak
of the four-sided love affair among the
young heartthrobs was entirely invented
for the film in fact the character of
Xander doesn't exist in the original
text while Carmen is mentioned only a
handful of times Desi meanwhile only
appears on a single page and he's dead
when he first appears Yes you heard that
correctly in the novel dizzy Flores is a
man he's a compatriot of Rico's in a
mobile infantry who buys it before the
story has barely begun as for Rico his
relationship with Carmen is more like an
unrequited Schoolboy Crush than anything
else Carmen is described as a woman who
will never settle down and is happy to
play the field and they're merely good
friends in the film it's quite the
opposite as Rico and Carmen's
relationship is a major plot points it
motivates him for much of the story
while their breakup makes him rethink
his service entirely in the book it's a
court martial of another soldier in boot
camp that makes Rico reassess his
decision Carmen only re-enters the story
much later when they catch up while on
leave and Rico is surprised to see her
with a shaved head
over the years Starship Troopers has
built a fervent fun following for its
thrilling Space Marine action but for
the movie spends less than 20 minutes in
boot camp training for the mobile
infantry and more than an hour at war
with the arachnids is actually the
reverse in the book more than half of
the novel is set during Rico's time in
training and it covers with great detail
his journey from fresh face recruit to
hardened Soldier his instructor Zim is
one of the few major characters in the
book compare the movie with the book and
you'll find that many of the boot camp
scenes from highline's novel are
translated into the film including Zim
challenging new recruits to a fight and
a soldier questioning him on why they
need to learn to use a knife but these
sequences play out very differently in
the book but they often spark lengthy
philosophical discussions on the nature
of war and power we give far more
insight into Rico's personal Journey the
importance a service holds to him and
the camaraderie he feels towards his
fellow soldiers When The War does break
out it's not nearly as dramatic in the
book it happens mostly off page with
Rico simply remarking that Earth had
gone from peace time to state of
emergency to war while you've been in
training
in Starship Troopers the arachnids are
an Unstoppable foe a race of primitive
insect Warriors that can tear through an
entire Earth army with ease there are
species that humans are intimately
familiar with Rico and his classmates
dissect them in score and the news
footage tells us who has been a fragile
piece for years but it's also hinted at
more than once other attack on Buenos
Aires the strike that triggers the war
was actually in response to human
intrusion the bugs we meet in heinlein's
book however are markedly different in
addition to being more human-sized
they're also known to be highly
intelligent and technologically advanced
they use traditional sci-fi weapons like
laser rifles with their own starships
and even cities on their home planets of
clendartho when they strike Buenos Aires
it's a clear Act of aggression and
there's never any suggestion that the
Terran Federation might have in any way
provoked a retaliatory assault the bugs
are evil they are the enemy they are a
dangerous hive mind hence the Communist
allegory and they are a clear and
present mortal threat to all human life
it's even said in the book bugs can
breed faster than the mobile infantry
can kill them able to produce new
soldiers almost on a whim like in the
movie their soldiers are near mindless
workers taking instruction from the
brain bugs that lurk beneath the surface
of the planet
in one of the most notable changes from
the novel the movie version of Starship
Troopers eliminated a key component of
the Space Marine Tech they're hulking
Mech suits as signature elements of the
book these suits in case each Soldier
like a mobile tank and much of the novel
goes into lengthy detail about their
capabilities benefits and drawbacks
there's such a major part of the story
that they appear on the cover of several
editions of the novel that have been
published over the years in addition
Rico and his fellow Roughnecks don't
just arrive PlanetSide on a simple drop
ship pouring out of their landing craft
like they're storming the beaches of
Normandy instead they drop from the sky
in their mechs-like rain inside Giant
capsules that crack open on impact these
techno capsules protect mobile infantry
soldiers from incoming enemy fire and of
course plenty of time is spent in the
book discussing their function and
hammering home the dangers of each drop
in other adaptations of the book
including a six-part anime from 1988 the
Meg suits play an integral role they
also show up in role-playing games and
the 2012 CGI animated movie given their
large role in the novel and importance
to the story the lack of the armored
suits in the movie is a big reason why
fans of the books sometimes struggle to
enjoy the film
one of the weirder elements in Starship
Troopers a movie already packed with
weirdness is the presence of psychic
powers we first learn of them through
Rico's friend Carl Jenkins when he plays
a special card game with Rico meant to
detect a latent psychic abilities Carl's
Powers allow him to read the thoughts of
non-humans and even implant suggestions
in their minds towards the climax though
after Carla spent some time working with
Military Intelligence has even hinted
that Carl has mastered the ability to
use his powers on people too but in the
novel there are no characters who
possess any kind of psychic abilities or
mind-reading Powers whatsoever certainly
not Carl who plays only a very tiny role
in the story it was seen that the
psychic abilities were invented for the
film perhaps as a way of allowing the
audience to understand the arachnid's
State of Mind in the ironic ending
however the movie doesn't completely
conjure them up out of nowhere in the
book there's a special branch of the
military a highly trained division of
the logistics and Communications group
called simply special talents though
they're not said to have any superhuman
Powers their agents are described as so
extraordinarily gifted that it borders
on Mariko calls black magic
much has been written about our Heinlein
Starship Troopers outlined the author's
own strongly held libertarian beliefs in
a military run authoritarian governments
that rejected 20th century ideals
perhaps nowhere in the novel was this
more laid bare than in the character of
Emilio Rico Johnny's father like their
film counterparts Johnny Rico's parents
are firmly against his decision to
enlist their staunchly anti-military and
his father who goes unnamed in the movie
forbids him to join the service this
mirrors some initial scenes in the book
but from there the story diverges
firstly the RICO family doesn't live in
Buenos Aires which becomes important
later on when the attack on Buenas Aires
occurs is only Johnny's mother who's
there apparently on vacation alone
Johnny's father is more openly
representative of liberal politics in
the book but when the bugs attack he has
a crisis of conscience that leads him to
re-evaluate his entire belief system
ultimately not only does Emilio Rico
become firmly pro-authoritarian but he
even enlists in the mobile infantry
himself later entering the story with
the war raging and now sergeants Johnny
Rico encounters his father while
transferring to a new ship in the film
both of Johnny's parents are killed at
the same time by the meteor attack which
is what motivates him to remain in the
service
the broad timeline and Starship Troopers
remains mostly the same from the book to
the movie with Rico joining the service
training before the arachnids attack
Earth after that the mobile infantry is
sent in to capture a brain bug in their
efforts to wipe out the enemy of course
there are plenty of changes in the story
too most of which come in the form of
the story's main characters in addition
to dizzy Flores being a male Soldier and
Carl not being a psychic the most
evident changes in Lieutenant radjac the
toughest Nails Commander played by
Michael Ironside in the film in the
movie Ironside plays a combination of
two different book characters the combat
leader of Rico's fighting force
lieutenant radjac and Mr Dubois his high
school history a moral philosophy
teacher Dubois plays a special role in
the novel as a letter he writes is what
inspires Rico to stay in the military
meanwhile book rajak is simply the
leader of the Roughnecks known to the
Troops only as the lieutenant he appears
only briefly but his death is a major
blow to the squad even after his passing
the soldiers continue to refer to the
new lieutenant by his old Rank and
behave as if radjac is still their
leader that's a far cry from what
happens in the movie When Johnny Rico
takes over
we promise when I'm making this one up
in heinlein's original Starship Troopers
in addition to Giant Killer bugs and
towering mech suit powered soldiers
there also exists a group of
cybernetically enhanced
hyper-intelligent canines called
neo-dogs these canine core members are
important animal soldiers mutated from
dog DNA not only are the neo-dog super
smart apparently as intelligent as a
human child but they can even talk
crudely they're limited by their vocal
capabilities they are said to be able to
articulate numerous human lingual sounds
and a well-trained Neo dog can learn a
human's accent well enough to
communicate with them Beyond just being
a soldier's best friend though the
relationship between the neo-dog and his
human partner is extremely profound as a
military recruitment officer tells Rico
when he's first applying for the service
if a canine Soldier is killed in action
the Neo dog is put down that's because
the bond that's been engineered is so
powerful that the animal would never be
able to recover from the death of their
human partner and while humans don't
receive the same death penalty should
their neo-dog my by the farm it can take
months to years of intense treatment for
soldiers to recover from the loss of
their canine comrade though the movie
completely ignores this element of the
book the Starship Troopers comics and
role-playing games have made use of
these Soldier perps when the Starship
Troopers movie opens we're given a
civics lesson on the status of
interstellar Affairs this includes the
introduction to the Terran Federation as
well as an overview of Earth's Galactic
neighbors the arachnids humans and
arachnids have a long history of
conflict as we're told that they've been
hurling asteroids at Earth for a while
thankfully Earth has powerful planetary
defenses capable of stopping most
attacks what the movie doesn't include
is another alien race from the books a
species not so kindly referred to as the
skinnies they're called that because as
you might guess they're tall slender
humanoid aliens they live on a civilized
Planet much like our own and while they
don't seem particularly aggressive Earth
is in the midst of an invasion of their
world when the book begins they're
described as being belligerents and the
war with the bugs often feeding the
enemy arachnids information that helps
them in their war on Earth later in the
war the skinny seemingly switched sides
apparently providing Intelligence on the
bugs are Aid in an assault on planet P
like the Neo dogs the skinnies also pop
up in several star Troopers games
outside of the movies as well as a
television series Roughnecks the
Starship Troopers Chronicles
[Music]